quand même le bon dieu je trouvais ça
assez raide
j'étais le bon dieu je ferai des jo
différent mais j'ai fait ça dans le but
d day
la cause que j'aime la ftq quand j'aime
les formes solidarité pigem salim puis
j'aime un système qui tente de l'ouvrir
aux travailleurs et pour les professeurs
vont pouvoir personnel concerne donc
plus d'ouvrir qu'est ce que vous auriez
fait différemment
qu'est ce que vous préférez c'est
poursuit-elle bon dieu fred et l'écho
différents vue complète de bon dieu que
je lui ferai un bon dieu première mère
ivre elle entend enfin qu'elle conjugue
va se poser mourir pour elle pourrait
faire des choses différentes
donc en ce qui concerne la sbq la solim
me font dire vous ne diriez fait
différemment
donc si je t'ai le bon dieu ferait des
choses différentes
ouais ça concernait pas ce que vous avez
fait au sein de la ftq fandi muslim ça
pourrait aller jusqu'à l'eau bon alors
c'est ce que je veux savoir qu'est ce
que vous auriez fait ces jours-ci que si
j'étais le bon dieu pour est définitive
mais regardez les choses que fred fermé
mais suppose on m'a tellement essuyé les
piges moins dans cette commission l'eau
en or pôle mail est incluse n'a parlé
j'ai pas vrai j'ai essayé de rein et
socke fait les quatre volontés pour tout
le monde va parler écouter parler de qui
on connaît pas dire zéro pour quelqu'un
qui est fausse j'ai toujours aidé
helmand dans le but faire avancer moore
mais pas dans le but d'en faire le
pouvoir policier jamais
dans tous les secteurs mais quinquis
passe d'une commission semblait bon il
ya du monde qui aime ce 6 juillet puis
surtout et puis il ya celle il ya said
de mettre des choses qui ont primé en
cours de route parce que quand elles
prises dans une section des présidents
de la ftq construction hinault sur ceux
qui aiment pas des choses que tu fais
mieux se protéger quand et en import 6
10 en 10 occasions comme l'oie sorte de
choses ou de calais et moi je suis pas
le genre de gars à calais par son prix
qu'elle jugeait qu'elle récite non plus
qu ici pour bébés seulement belle
réponse dans ça